[Music]
boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host on shotgun
super pumped to be talking about
theoretical linguistics
we have Marco you keep showing us on the
show hello let's go down pleasure to
meet you yes such a pleasure super
grateful that we were introduced by Mike
Johnson quality surgeon to team good day
yeah super grateful for them and I've
been loving reading your work about
figuring out how to effectively be able
to learn languages practically learn
languages this is really fascinating
your backgrounds really cool so
theoretical linguist developing methods
that are effective and practical to
learn new languages studied Arabic
Russian German Latin English and many
more languages that's right
and the links in the bio are to his
website where he has a tremendous amount
of posts and visuals about this is
really good also the Twitter link is
below let's start with this big history
perspective like we find ourselves as
stewards of earth what is your current
take on the state of humanity yeah I
mean it's it's an interesting time you
know if you if you look at the history
of humanity it's a it's only been ten
twenty thousand years since we've had a
civilization as far as I know although
I've heard some theories that that goes
deeper into the past than we that we
know right now only had industrial
civilization for two hundred years maybe
250 if you if you really go back and
look at the roots maybe we've had that
perform we just don't know about it
anymore because there was a catastrophic
collapse far back in the past but we
don't know that for sure yet maybe and
now we're entering the the the
information era basically it looks like
right we've got a less you know there's
a there's a famous Peter teal quote or
whatever about Twitter and flying cars
you know we we thought we'd get flying
cars instead we got Twitter you know
that says something about a the the the
the state of technological development
these days and it's very much it's very
much going into the micro instead of the
macro
no no galactic spaceships yet you know
we'll see what SpaceX does but uh yeah
it's interesting it's interesting man
and it looks like at the same time we're
kind of at a kind of at an inflection
point I think with with everything
that's going on at the same time we're
having a lot of crazy developments in
information technology you've got your
blockchain you've got your you know
facial recognition
you know augmented reality virtual
reality all this stuff and and yet at
the same time were maybe it maybe looks
like we're having more political and
like social problems than ever and maybe
that stuff is related but ya know man
it's I don't know I don't know how the
world will look even 50 years from now
right you know I don't even know how to
look a year or two from now let alone 50
but uh maybe looks like the the
possibility space is a greater than it
ever has been before we could have an AI
singularity as a lot of people think
think will happen or maybe the the whole
thing collapses and we're going back to
pre-industrial you know tribal
civilization as some other people think
will happen and so we really got the
whole spectrum of outcomes basically it
looks like and me personally I'm not
making any bets I think it's best to
prepare for all possible outcomes I I
guess I'm not so certain about either of
the extremes but you know we don't
really know what's going to happen so
we're just going to have to deal with
the consequences I like you I like your
take on the state of humanity a lot
especially the the teal quote on we
wanted flying cars and we got 140
characters instead it's a very profound
quote it it really does teach about are
we thinking on the moonshot galactic
perspective and a civilization or are we
thinking about building an app for a
phone yeah so this this really gives a
solid perspective also I want to know
how you picked up your interest in
linguistics yeah growing up you're only
23 I'm 23 yeah yeah yeah I'm a young gun
I'm a young gun although you know I
wasn't wasn't that long ago when I was
19 and I have to say I feel I feel much
older now believe it or not that's just
the you know the bliss of youth maybe
but um ya know I mean I
I've got an interesting background I
usually hate explaining it but I you
know I guess we're here I I must i grew
up bilingual speaking croatian in
english my my dad spoke English with me
my mom Croatian and ironically you know
it's kind of a funny story the the first
language I ever spoke was was actually
Slovenian which I no longer speak and so
what happened was when I was a little
baby you know 1 or 2 years old whatever
it was we were living in Slovenia and
and my parents said one day you know
it's it's time to teach him how to speak
so they sit me down my my dad comes in
with a ball and he's like you know ball
ball my mom is like love that which is
you know Croatian football night and I
look at them and I say Geauga because I
learned that from the kids on the
playground already and you know how was
I was confused I was like what's you
know come on you know ball what is this
and so anyway you know I I manely got
more interesting from there basically
over the next 20 years or whatever let's
see I I lived abroad most of my life a
whole bunch of countries that you know
you've never heard of and I guess I just
got a lot of exposure to languages and
linguistics basically both my parents
spoke like spoker studied about five six
languages each you know I'm I study
German and French in elementary school
studied as Airi at one point which was
very interesting asar by John exactly so
it's a Turkic language I lived there for
a few years growing up and basically
around the time I was 15 or 16 I sort of
thought to myself hey I can you know you
know I sort of you know grew into my own
consciousness if that makes sense and I
realized I can I can learn languages
myself in my own time I don't I don't
need to learn everything I want to learn
in school basically yes and so I
actually discovered duolingo before it
was even released and I'm sure you know
about duolingo so yeah yeah I don't I
don't
what if our viewers don't yes oh so
duolingo duolingo is a great site a lot
of users now basically they give you
free language learning lessons in these
very tightly created courses it's very
it's very gamified it's got like you
know you start off with simple phrases
and sentences you kind of you know
expand and you cover a bunch of topics
and it's all free and I think originally
their their business plan was that they
would teach people languages and then
have them translate documents for for
clients and then eventually they they'd
drop that and just switch to
certification from what I understand
so that's duolingo still a great
resource totally recommended so yeah III
I got into duolingo 15 16 I was on the
prebate or whatever studied Spanish
Portuguese Italian you know they had a
you know a couple different languages
they got a lot more now and it was
around that time that I started noticing
like interesting you know as I've said
before maybe glitches in the matrix when
it comes to language learning yeah
unpack that a bit yeah sure sure so this
might be getting into my my theory in
getting into theory yeah this is giving
people yeah journey and sure sure sure
yeah so let's see
starting out he's noticing some glitches
in the matrix eventually went to college
and I decided I love languages so much
that I would study nothing but languages
at college so I took German Arabic
Russian and Latin all simultaneously
after about a year and a half they
basically said you know this you can't
major in learning languages you can do
linguistics if you want or you can
choose one language but you can't just
study a bunch of them and so I thought
well this is really what I enjoyed about
college and so shortly after I started
majoring I just dropped out instead yeah
and then went on went on a journey
basically through an entrepreneurship
and cryptocurrency you know it's my jobs
here and there did some more language
studies sort of made my way in the world
and yeah I eventually got enough money
that I could do this more or less
full-time and so that's that's what I've
been focusing on recently and I'm
actually trying to write a book now on
the on the topic try and get the whole
the problem I've written a few articles
on the problem I'm gonna start getting
into the the solution the method and the
theory behind a behind a possible
solution I'm not quite done with that
yet I'm in the process of finishing it
and I think over the next year or two
will alone will get that done hopefully
and you're gonna give us some hints at
what you've been learning as well as
what are some of your solution yes
exactly
we'll definitely talk about that yeah
yeah it's it's really interesting
hearing about your upbringing where
your parents spoke five six languages
each that you know even when you're
young it's like you know ball hope duh
yeah third one it's like you know even
having an object that has these
different in just that in itself having
a different word I believe it was it's
down to on the Rosetta project with long
now yes some what is it down to just a
couple thousand languages now our
circulation like five thousand or so
yeah it's a few thousand it's a few
thousand I remember probably looking at
National Geographic maps growing up that
said seven to eight you know that might
have decreased by now actually I don't
know the exact number myself I do know
if you if you go even further and you
look at major world languages or even a
fifth year you're starting to reach
basically even at 50 so that yeah a lot
of language stuff yeah and it's like
Mandarin Arabic English are already like
what is that like five billion people or
something for Bill yeah probably
ridiculously yeah Mandarin Alone's got
to be one and a half billion you know
and then Hindi to Hindi yeah your
Spanish yeah
Spanish says those like whatever that is
six languages are Leah five billion
people or something creates a Pareto
principle present principle yeah yeah
yeah and so that is this is one of these
things that that we could we could you
know we're gonna talk about this as well
this is this big history of of language
actually this would be good to talk
about I just want said one more thing
about your upbringing I'm really happy
that you've had this not only you had
technology yeah your fingertips
something like a dual lingo
all right you wanted to pick it up and
you had this self-motivated learning
which we see us so much now in
Millennials Gen Z and younger these
little gradients of micro generations
going down it's now they can pick up
something and learn it as much as they
want also you know the collegiate system
used to adapt like if they you know if
you wanted to go and study things make
your own major type thing definitely
okay so now let's let's do this so you
know and you initially said like the
start of civilization we don't actually
quite know if it had previously
collapsed before what it had what has
happened exactly but something that we
do know is that it seems to be through
the examples of things like writing and
art work and hieroglyphics and and
Dean presses and all the way up to now
the Internet we do hypothesize about
things like grunting and things like
forming these initial words so it's to
teach us about that big history with
language the big history of language
let's see I don't think we actually know
when and why language came to exist it
goes so far back in our evolutionary
past that we we really don't have any
good idea how it went down which is
extremely interesting to me because it
is maybe one of it is an extremely
complicated system in terms of the
conceptual relationships and the
structures that we have it's like it's
it's a very large amount of information
there are very large amounts of
vocabulary it's hard to imagine how it
how it sort of popped up out of nowhere
so it probably didn't but it's also hard
to imagine how it evolved basically
right and so it's it's it's still a big
question that we that we don't know too
much about about the farthest back that
we can go you know one one interesting
fact that I like to you know I like to
use this like a bit of an example with
people is a writing language entirely
preceded writing very interesting most
of the language that we look at today is
isn't writing I would I would guess
right people are looking at their phones
they're looking at their computers
they're reading books they're reading
signs this will talk a lot you know for
now you know people people still use
speech obviously although less than in
the past maybe but language was you know
totally it was it was fully complete in
terms of complexity and meaning and
whatnot before before writing ever came
about you know when the first people
invented writing as far as we can tell
they they already had a complex language
they weren't grunting when they came up
with writing you know the the first the
first I forget if it's the first written
work the Iliad is like the first piece
of literature in the Western canon and
it dates back to like a thousand BC or
maybe earlier and the Iliad is very very
long and very complex you know it's got
ancient Greek at that time had a lot of
cases it was grammatically complex they
had a very complex vocabulary they had a
lot of gone
they had a lot of names they had these
complex narratives and stories and all
of this was transmitted orally in
generation to generation long before
they ever invented writing and and and
when they did invent writing it started
off as little you know sort of the the
written equivalent of grunts maybe you
know little little pictures that
eventually became you know character
kind of based system sort of like
Chinese is now eventually alphabets
which we still use today I know I went
off on a bit of a tangent there so it's
it's it's it's really really interesting
thinking about how when we're looking
all the way back at these first initial
ways of representing information yeah
yeah this is this is what's nuts how did
we the communication collaboration yeah
it's such a huge part of the human
evolution so yeah talk about the
relationship of that language with a
piece of information and being able to
you know draw that out communicate it to
someone else right I mean yeah look it's
like you know we can see we can see
animals communicating in different ways
on you might say mostly through body
language some of them have but you know
some of the I mean some of them are a
lot of a lot of animals make noises of
different kinds and some of them use
those to communicate I think scientists
have been looking at whales dolphins
maybe maybe apes like gorillas and
monkeys in terms of you know what kind
of they've got like you know maybe it's
a secret okay yeah exactly see what it's
thinking what they're communicating it's
like was I gonna say so yeah some of
them like maybe they have high-pitched
high-pitched grunts or noises for
certain things lower pitch lines from
different ones so they're they're you
know you can sort of see something like
a proto proto-language I mean it's hard
to even call it a language it's
definitely a system of communication but
comes to animals and so we can maybe
assume that humanity had something
similar but it's like you know I think
they say the the
key thing about human language that
makes it such such a killer sort of
adaptation for the human race is that um
it's um you can sort of languages such
that with with a small amount of rules
and words basically concepts you're able
to produce on an infinite amount of
sentences an infinite amount of meanings
right and that's very useful for the
world we live in because the world we
live in is extremely complicated lots of
things we don't know about lots of new
things if you're out there on the
African savannah or whatever you know
500,000 years ago I don't quite know
that dates exactly but figuring out how
to how to communicate complex
relationships information about
relationships in the world that is you
know more than just a warning or a you
know verbal attack or something which
are you know sort of the things that
animals can do would be extremely
extremely useful it basically allows you
to communicate your experiences of the
world to other other human beings pass
that down to children yes
exactly which allows for cultural
transmission basically over generations
over time so so now you're able to you
know if you can only grunt and make you
know like for example a warning is a
good example of the kind of thing you
can do with a grunt you know like when
you grunt that's a warning there's a
predator around now imagine instead of
you know that's sort of like that's
limited in time and an area you can only
make the grunt once it's like a limited
space they can hear it it's limited over
time it's only relevant for a short
while
once you have language you can now as
you said you know transmit that
culturally to children over generations
now you can have you know pieces of
information that exists for longer than
human lives and you can with language
transmit it to many many people at once
and like they can tell each other they
can say oh Alan told me this you know
and then someone else could say yeah
Alan told someone that he told me this
like now the information lives you know
across multiple human beings instead of
just one in over a long period of time
very interesting stuff very good stuff
yeah
and that's that's building of the
foundation of collective learning over
time Zak and that's that this is why it
we've
managed to have such a complex design
world now that way yeah we're so
privileged Olivia you know 80 years in
and and and have the access to the tools
that give us this
these these abilities to summon things
so quickly and now okay on on a on on a
let's get into the the granularity on
the latter side of things so that was
more on the on the more recent side or
the more on the more historical side of
things now it's you know eight billion
people video calling each other across
the planet hundreds of millions of
emails being sent every couple of hours
these are like crazy crazy statistics
yeah a lot of communication yeah yeah a
lot of communication maybe even too much
overly saturated on the communication
the amount of tweets and show hosts and
stuff like that where's the signal yeah
I know this is interesting so if you if
you look at how complex and technical
and granular language can be if you look
at the you know the very specific
meanings of of words and of grammatical
structures I think once you understand
this more more deeply which many people
don't for whatever reason you know
grammar used to be part of the Trivium
which was logic rhetoric and grammar
that would be like the basic thing they
taught in like classical schools now
nobody really looks at it so a lot of
people don't sort of think about this
but if you do and you look at all this
communication that's happening an
interesting thing is that I think 90% of
communication that's that's that's out
there on like Twitter for example first
of all does not even it is not even
meant to be sort of cooperative
communication it's meant to be just
rhetoric it's it's the verbal equivalent
it's like a grunt in fact it's the
verbal equivalent of an angry grunt at
someone else like people arguing not
really intending to get to the bottom of
an issue and learn something from each
other but just trying to attack and be
down the other person right yeah so in a
way they're they're not even using
language it looks like language
but they're not really using it to
communicate you know things about the
about the world they're using it to
attack each other that's I would say
that's like 90% I may be exaggerating
then of that 10% that's left over I
would say 90% of that is just people
have not agreed on the correct
definitions of words essentially and so
although they might be trying to to
learn something from each other in a
cooperative way about the world using
language they end up basically they they
don't they don't realize that they're
using different definitions or terms or
have different ideas about what what
they are talking about in their heads
and so they they just can't ever reach a
resolution like you might say they're
stuck on semantics and so 1% of all
communication that's going on the real
signal yeah it 1% might be the real
signal where people totally understand
what they're talking about are able to
talk about it very well and are
intending to talk about it and and learn
something new with each other being a
quantumness exactly exactly learn
exactly yeah so I think one person of
communication you know just just just
because somebody is talking doesn't mean
it's communication right that's a very
that's a very interesting point to even
sin that that the intent behind that
those messages are like beating you down
rather than let's learn from each other
yeah exactly yeah I want to understand
you
yeah oh you got to where you are today
completely different yeah approach yeah
with that intent and and and if you
think about it back when a language
emerged from the evolutionary you know
the evolutionary soup it's like you
wouldn't need a language if you if you
were just trying to beat down on other
people you wouldn't need it so wouldn't
evolve from that you would need language
if you were trying to communicate
information and people would actually
have to use it so you might say that
language itself has its its nature is
cooperative right because of this it is
it is the cooperative nature that would
make it necessary in the first place
so the the if the if the if the if the
nature of language is for it to be used
cooperatively we see now language being
used in a non cooperative way which what
could have length it seems like was was
language potentially be used in other
ways as well that were not cooperative
in the past oh definitely yeah
definitely
control well control could be a type of
cooperation actually if you look at like
if you look at like a large state right
like like this is something I talk about
sometimes two states historically have a
huge interest in in language and the
language people use because much like
you need language to cooperate a state
in in a way as is built on the
cooperation of large numbers of people
in specific ways and so to have that you
they all need to speak a standard
language and so you see the Soviet Union
tries to standardize Russian across
across all of its territories China in
the 50s and 60s simplifies its character
system that used to have traditional
characters than they I think they were
they were planning to actually replace
it with the Roman alphabet even because
it would it will be a lot easier it
would greatly simplify the the sort of
needs of the bureaucracies into the
state in terms of like you know I mean
just writing anything basically but they
ended up not doing that for reasons that
I'm not totally certain of but they did
simplify the the character system
something like only 40 percent of France
at the time of the French Revolution
French Revolution spoke French they had
a lot of other languages back then as
well in France sort of local languages
that don't really exist anymore and they
don't exist because the state instituted
French as is the language that everybody
would speak and this allows everybody to
coordinate basically around the state
however yes you can definitely use
language in a non-cooperative way but
that would probably be the the least
useful thing you could do with language
although people will still do it yeah
you know how mean it's sort of like is
that you called it the evolutionary soup
and then it's interesting because of the
amount of
of ways that we formed languages and
then the ways that we to cooperate and
then the ways that we also ended
languages in order to have people
cooperate in within countries with yes
with Indian nations this though you and
I we could spend hours just talking
about yeah the evolution on the big
history side of language and how it's
always now versus back in evolution but
we need to talk about the theory we need
to talk about this so we have this
theory of the theory of learning
language is wrong as your as your
premise and I like this a lot because it
already starts off with the way that
we're learning things is wrong and then
that ideal way is that we need a clear
success condition yes
which they'll be when yeah when the
pretty much the clear success condition
right now is like you go through
learning like English in the United
States and then it's like can you speak
English and the answer is yes yeah you
can speak right yeah yeah yeah the
question is what is that it wouldn't say
yeah yeah yeah yeah and further
languages and we have we have slides to
walk us through so yeah so we can pull
them up now as we go through yeah yeah
we do the the first slide that would be
good all right so here is your here's
your you know you're talking about the
theory of language learning here is the
current theory this is sort of implicit
it's it's often not so implicit it's
often explicit oh let's go back I'm
sorry no worries no worries we'll get
we'll get to this gibberish in a moment
this is basically your mainstream
paradigm explaining what it means to
speak a language or to know a language
even some fluency you've got your
speaking listening writing and reading
slw are oh it's Auto probably ok it's
all good it's all good now I wanted to
be a janitor so yeah this is your
mainstream definition of what of what
language ability is if you look at
course descriptions at major
universities if you look at the way
martial language products are broken up
in terms of what what the courses
consist of this is usually how it's done
you've got production and you've got
reception morale and written there's you
know if you want to you can communicate
a language in Morse code or Braille or
other things but generally people don't
learn that they just speak it or they
write it and read it and this is
basically all there is to it this is the
this is the theoretical underpinning
that explains why language learning
courses and products are the way that
they are right
this explains why they have the things
they have why they have um you know
drills exercise it's like the whole
shebang you know all that stuff cultural
cultural sort of little explanations
like I you know I could I could go on
this for a while you have a lot of
different products and they all vary a
little bit but they all share this idea
of a language is that which you can
speak listen read and write yeah and
those four things are essentially
indefinitely improvable skills those
four things right the idea is you want
to practice these four skills as they
relate to a particular language and you
just keep practicing them forever that's
basically what it is and it's funny I I
used to you know I used to ask sort of
my professors in college so so when will
I speak Russian fluently and what they
would say is well you never really stop
learning a language which is true in a
sense it's true in a sense however we do
know that there are fluent speakers of
languages and non fluent speakers and
people actually generally don't really
question who is who right like the the
distribution of language skill if it was
true that you you never really stopped
learning language and that you might
think the the sort of you might think
the the progression of skill over time
to be linear or maybe it will be you
know maybe look like this maybe it would
look like this but you would think that
you would think that you'd have a sort
of even distribution of skill but if you
actually look at people out there who
speak languages if you take any
individual language it should it's it's
much more like a I think it's called a
binomial distribution that might be the
wrong word but it's it's it's bifurcated
and you have a lot of people who don't
speak it very few people in the middle
and then you have a lot of people who
are fluent right it's kind of like this
it's kind of
you you and then on the side of usually
not speaking yet it's really high and
then those and then the partial speakers
is very low and the speakers are higher
than that exactly exactly and so that's
interesting that's interesting that
suggests this is is not actually true
right it suggests that there's a there's
something that needs to be done that
will get you to fluency and people are
just not doing it basically and then
this is also this is also interesting
because then it says that the two ways
of engaging with language is to either
go out or receive in produce or receive
us and that there what it would have
like how else are there ways to have a
shared experience about an object or
feeling or experiences that way and then
what else is there past oral and written
what what else is you thought yeah yeah
there's so many other ways of you this
is you know this is something that we
need to evolve past and it's surprising
that you know maybe some of the
spiritual leaders of the past thousands
of years prior to today yeah if we're
way past this type of connection - yeah
oh well they they definitely had a
deeper connection and when we get into
the the limits of language we might we
will talk about that okay cool so that
this is on language ability and it's
also ridiculous that the the curriculum
seems like it's it's not the success
condition like where is the success
condition on that distribution and yeah
yeah they don't have them basically they
don't have and I think that's the
entirety of the problem right and if you
try to solve that problem you get you
get everything else that we'll get into
in a second here and it comes to a
solution to this problem basically all
right let's go all let's move on then so
well this gin Adeeb loop grad oped
sting willie through the ear edited hun
walls up pollute tooth alright so here
we have a a nonsense sentence this is a
gibberish sentence the sentence does not
mean anything that that we recognize but
there are a few interesting things about
this you know go to the next slide even
though all of the words almost all the
words we have
you know more more common words here
just to tie it together but only three
even though the vast majority of the
words in the sentence are are total
gibberish when you when you speak this
sentence we both immediately recognize
that it is English and the even more
interesting thing is that we we
recognize all of these conceptual
structures that tie the words together
even though we don't know what they mean
so even though we don't know what a
bloop is we know that it is
gennadiy we is right in a deep blue
exactly virginity blue we we have no
idea what these two words mean but we
are getting some information we gain
that the gennadiy is the adjective exact
that the bloop is the now exactly yeah
we know that the bloop word opt we know
that it read opt in a stint wily way we
know that the hon Wald was a redditor
breaking this creaky bringing stuff like
this yeah this is herb exactly so so we
know that we know the bloop grid opt and
we know that it that you know because
it's past tense we recognize the past
and sort of morphology the edie at the
end there we know that this happened in
the past we we recognize the ly
morphology indicating most likely an
adverb so you know that the the grid
opping happened in a you know stin wily
way we can recognize the T y could also
be a sort of adjective on morphology so
we recognize that it's referring to the
bloop the blue there's no there's no
particularly common morphology they're
indicating what part of speech it is so
we know it's most likely a noun
am I missing anything there's probably
about it yeah yeah through through the
you know nothing strange there those are
common English words and we know that II
read did Ted you know the eg arrives
again but this time and being the sort
of IDI that you have in the in the verb
we we recognize due to the placement of
words with hon Wald and the apostrophe s
indicating it's a noun and the
possessive we know that this is also an
adjective and it's it's an adjective
referring to to us something that was a
reddit reddit it it was a reddit ting
something else was irritating this thing
in the past right
of course we get to the apalla tus also
nonsense word we know that the the
apalla to spa long to the unwalled due
to the apostrophe s which is a
possessive morphology basically it's
crazy that this sentence although is
gibberish yes we can still go you still
break down these grammar points yeah
exactly in a gibberish sentence exactly
so what's the meaning behind that the
meaning behind that is that a language
is is not primarily its vocabulary a
language is is more than the words that
make it up basically even though most of
the words here mean nothing that we know
of we still we still immediately absorb
this this wealth of meaning about the
words that are there when it is spoken
and so this is this is very very very
interesting basically because you could
imagine you could imagine a language or
a system of communication where we're
the sort of this sort of these rich
conceptual structural relationships were
we're either not very important or not
there whatsoever and the the entirety of
the meaning consisted of sort of
individual blocks of content words right
but we don't have that we have these
very very implicit structures that we
call grammar and syntax and you could go
into morphology as well that essentially
essentially represent very basic
features of human reality which I will
also get to when it comes to case in a
second very basic things like
cause-effect yeah time right these are
like these are like when you when you
when you talk about a when you say the
words glass of water a glass of water is
a very you know real specific act not an
abstract thing yeah when you're looking
at grammatical categories and things
like this your your these the content
that is represented there is not
something that's real and immediate like
a glass of water or an object it's
something very abstract but that is
applicable to a lot of situations right
and so it's probably not a coincidence
that that is how it turned out
when it comes to communication yeah this
is so so nice
I know yeah how could how could one have
this this is such an interesting
discovery that you're highlighting that
that that we have this like grammar
syntax so many of these things that one
can make sense of figuring out what our
adjectives would are nouns in here yeah
the verb the verb is past tense there's
an en D it's just it's ridiculous that
that yeah that the the what was the
phrase that that grew at that grow the
way that grammar relates to the grammar
is sort of communicating the most the
most basic aspects of human reality yeah
essentially the most basic and more so
than even the language yeah the way yeah
exactly more than the words more than
words more than the words is the way
that we place things in order yes a
string together meaning yes exactly
exactly interesting and that these
things have meaning even when the words
have none Yeah right correct yeah this
all of a sudden has some meaning yeah
yeah correct and this is also extremely
interesting as we're feeding artificial
intelligence which we'll talk yet later
because how do you want to feed that
what code do you want to get back so
yeah okay let's go on to next next one
and so this this starts getting into a
solution to the problem of language
learning why so many people fail to
learn languages this is a visual system
that I've come up with for representing
grammatical case so what is grammatical
case a lot of English speakers
especially don't know what cases because
English arguably doesn't have case
arguably it does but even if it does is
very limited case is the reason that you
say she is there I saw her case is the
difference between she and her Oh
interesting yeah you don't say any twice
her toys exactly is there exactly don't
say her is there and you don't say I saw
she you say I saw her she is there now
what's the reason the reason is that she
in that in in that sentence she is there
is the it's called the subject in in
linguistics her is called the object now
this is usually how its explained to a
students in the classroom and usually
they go mmhmm okay and then they think
what what does that mean they still
don't get it I'm just gonna remember
yeah exactly I'm just gonna memorize
that I'm gonna remember it but I still
don't really understand why it's like
this let alone when they get into more
complicated languages that that have
even more cases like a German or Russian
or Finnish and Hungarian have like 10 or
15 each then they're completely lost
right and so and I think that is
actually the the main problem with
language learning is that people can't
imbibe the grammatical structures of new
languages that those structures have
those structures exist in those
languages but but people don't know how
to learn them basically and we don't
even do a good job of explaining what
they are and so this is is my beginning
to a solution to this problem nominative
case you will you will see we've got a
nice little circle here that's an is
very subject goes yeah it's in the
locative case that's more complicated
I'll get to that in mono the nominative
case is the case that the good was never
born okay so the the subject is always
in the nominative case that's what they
say she right she would go there okay
her would go here accusative accusative
the direct object now when you're
explaining I saw her she is they're not
quite clear what's going on if you start
drying diagrams like this you know a lot
of people are visually you know we're
very visual animals basically now you
might start to get around you might um
you might
what's the word you might get a shortcut
around
sort of directly linguistic explanation
what's going on here her the direct
object is the thing that is being acted
on according to the verb which you might
conceive of as as the as the arrow here
okay the subject is the thing which is
doing doing the doing the verb basically
okay so you'll have a sentence like I
saw her her is being seen yeah yeah I
would be the subject there in the
nominative ice I saw Alan yeah right yes
it did dative do the the data the data
would be I gave Alan the book okay then
Alan would be the dative you would be
yeah exactly
Alan yes or the book is the book is the
direct object exactly the book would be
the direct object it would be the
accusative because it is the book that
is being given right so I remember all
these I remember very very little but I
remember words like this that we're
initially taught but then you're right
there's this period of like I'm not
gonna look at this I'm just gonna yeah
I'm just gonna remember eyes the way
that these things are kind of structured
yeah and then I'm gonna try and sound as
literate yes exactly that's kind of like
the the math that we do in our heads
that's kind of the process actually it's
interesting you mentioned that because I
sometimes like to say you know most
people don't know this most people I
like to say don't even know how to speak
their own language they know how to do
it but they don't know why they don't
understand the sort of technical
structures that are that are sort of
being processed and it's true the sort
of the mental way that they think about
it is I'm going to try and sound as
literate as possible I'm going to try
and imitate the people who sound the
best that I have heard in a language I
don't know I probably don't know this I
probably don't know too much about
linguistics or grammar or any formal
structures but but I'm a human I'm good
at imitating you know and I'm gonna do
it a lot and it tends to work out it
tends to work out right it tends to work
out the people if you ask them could not
explicate the stuff which is you know
which is very interesting it's like
become a black box in it yeah oh it's
totally a black box it's totally a black
bar
and it's it's super fascinating that
everybody who is alive essentially there
might be people who can't speak any
language whatsoever if they grew up in
the wild and can't understand a button
you know I mean even people who are mute
understand language every single person
in the world has a system this is just
case there are maybe 40 to 50
grammatical categories is what they're
called sort of elements of grammar that
have been identified among human
languages broadly major world languages
maybe use like 20 to 30 depending on
which ones you're looking at this is
just one of them yeah exactly
Geron grammar patterns yes they're
essentially patterns of grams and and
you said there's maybe 20 to 30 grammar
patterns in like English and Mandarin
Arabic yeah broadly so English would
have less Arabic would have less but if
you take like the top 50 major world
languages they'd have like maybe 20 to
30 grammatical categories like between
them that are used interesting in the
most most schools when you're learning
English give you some of these 20 to 30
yeah grammatical patterns okay they
probably teach you some like tense is
well-known gender number definiteness
yeah I could go on but those are the
sort of things it's like the most common
ones present tenses easily injure exact
yeah exactly and so you could draw sort
of visual diagrams for all of these
things basically to explain them and
they they don't exist basically there's
there's no way to represent this
visually and the reason I like it is
because you can um typically when you're
explaining grammatical structures in a
linguistics class the only way you can
do it is by referencing individual
languages so I'll try to explain
nominative and accusative case to you
and what I'll have to do is bring it
bring up examples in a couple languages
and then give you a a a a linguistic
explanation for what this is but you
cannot reference it without reference to
any individual language even though
these things are common across languages
so what I like about the visual system
and the reason I'm developing this is
because it gives you like basically a a
neutral reference for these structures
that exist in multiple languages and so
you could do a lot more diagrams like
this and it's very interesting that even
though these these extremely complex
systems
every single person's head almost nobody
could explain them if asked even though
they use them all the time very
interesting yeah very interesting yeah
yeah you you said it earlier that we we
we know the we knew we we say we know a
language but when asked to double click
into that yeah I love how you're doing
visual representations yeah that's
really interesting and then if by
breaking this down with examples like
below where you are gonna write this out
for people to understand it I think
it'll be really interesting to be this
is your double click in yeah exactly
I've used this with some some people
that I'm helping learn languages and
preliminary evidence so far it works it
works once you show an English speaker
this and then explain the case system it
sticks they know what to do and this is
a big hurdle for English speakers who
learn foreign languages with case the
the classic example I have is one I when
I took German class in high school it
was me and three Americans I mean I'm
American too but but the key thing is
they did not speak Croatian which I did
small class intimate setting the teacher
could give each one of us lots of
attention so it's not like we were
dozing off in class or anything you know
we were all focused on actually the
other three of them had studied German
before and I had nots they even had
maybe a bit of an advantage and we're
learning German it's going well until we
get to to the case system in German
German has four cases nominative
accusative dative and genitive it
doesn't have instrumental or locative
that's more like Slavic languages but it
does have those for English arguably has
done or has these three in limited forms
and so when when the native English
speakers start learning German case
they're they're learning how how words
are inflected they are changed depending
on what case the word is in but they
don't quite understand why
it's like that it's not obvious to them
it's not intuitive and so what happens
is they start memorizing these different
forms like you know you can say a deer
hunt which is like of a dog or you can
say Dane hunt which is also the dog but
it would be in a different a circle if
you drew it out on this diagram a
different case okay and they can't they
don't know you know they can memorize
which one to use in different situations
but there's actually a lot of overhead
for them to memorize that because
they're not learning the principle or
the system they're just memorizing that
in this case it has to be this and this
one it has to be this and what happens
is they they just don't learn it very
well okay because then they're almost
using an additional amount of let's say
this neural real estate in order to
you're out where dog or how to change
the word dog yeah and where depending on
where it goes exact and then they would
have to do that same thing for cat and
the same thing for each like animal
let's hair thing versus if they learned
the principle then but they would fall
in it it actually goes deeper it
actually goes deeper what they're trying
to do is remember every single instance
of a sentence where it would be
nominative versus accusative versus
native versus genitive and because
because they don't understand the
principle it's not intuitive to them
they haven't understood it they haven't
grok tit if you will they're trying to
memorize these cases light light like
like it would like they would say on if
you have if you have a sentence with
with the verb to be then it's always
nominative right and you can say in the
case of in case you're referring to
possession of something then it'll
probably be genitive right and like
they'll sort of give these examples and
then what we'll have to do is they'll
try and remember like the ways these
different sentences look and then try
and guess what the right cases but
there'll be it'll it'll be sort of like
they're memorizing that instead of
understanding the principle of case what
is why is case there because it's not
actually arbitrary although when you
learn it like this it seems like it is
basically it seems like just pointless
complexity but it's not it's actually
grunt you know a lot of people think
grammar is like uh something boring and
complex and useless and annoying and
arbitrary but it's not if it was it
probably wouldn't survive to the present
day it's actually
it actually simplifies language and
communication people just don't realize
how and to wrap this anecdote up when
they were having trouble learning case I
was not to me it was intuitive it's very
interesting why because Croatian also
has the same cases and then some and so
that was one of the glitches and the
matrix like I mentioned before if you if
you know a language that has certain
grammatical structures you can
essentially instantly sort of reapply
those structures to a new language using
different words and different morphology
different inflection different like
actual things that you produce but you
know how the conceptual relationships
between them work immediately and it
doesn't require any explanation and so
the gap that's missing the sort of gap
that's missing in learning is teaching
those conceptual structures directly
right as opposed to letting them seep in
over time naturally which for most
people just never happens and that's why
so few people know how to learn
languages and so this this is what this
that is the problem that this is meant
to solve basically mm-hmm okay so this
is a big part of this is one's ability
to learn it learned a principle set
grammar pattern language and be able to
apply that also to another language
exactly okay okay and and for certain
ones it will be different yeah grammar
patterns but yeah exactly
you'll have different sets of patterns
and whatnot so here's a here's an
English example of again English does
not quite have grammatical case but the
the the meaning that case is is
producing is still in English the
conceptual relationships so here you
have the man of the house gave the woman
the book in English you don't really
inflict these words depending on case
but the same conceptual relationship
still exists the man is the subject he
the man in the sentence sort of has the
essence of existing and when combined
with the accusative is sort of the cause
as opposed to the accusative
effectiveness
you've got your woman in the data of
theirs in direct contact
with the giving of the book and the man
is produced from the house you can see
the arrow is sort of you know more or
less sort of intuitively display this
bright basically right if you took if
you took this the meaning of this
sentence in in a number of other
languages all you would do is is replace
the words in the circles but the
relationship would stay the same right
and that would show you what the
conceptual relationship between these
things is right so if you go to the next
slide I have a simpler example here
we're doing this in Croatian German and
English right
you've got totally different languages
here totally different languages same
words with the same meaning but the
thing that stays the same other than
just the meanings of the words you could
actually you could actually change the
words you know in different ways and you
would still have the same conceptual
relationship I'm repeating myself now
but you still have the same conceptual
relationship right and that same
conceptual relationship is grammatical
case and it's reapplied over and over
and over and over again and almost
everything that you might say because
what you have here is you have a
grammatical structure that is conveying
the meaning of something like existence
it's implicitly conveying the meaning
that a word you say is merely existing
right if you have the dative case and
you use a word in the dative case you
are conveying the meaning that that this
word this object has some sort of
contact with the verb that you are using
okay you're conveying the meaning of
this contact without saying get out
right in a word if you have accusative
you're conveying the meaning that this
thing and the accusative is affected by
the thing in the nominative right with
the nominative in the accusative you
sort of get this cause-and-effect
relationship basically nominative alone
is sort of like exists it's like I am
here that's that will be a nominative
statement is this a big part of grammar
patterns is cause-and-effect the
locations of these words yes yes it
looks pretty big yet we're referring to
objects or people yeah
the outside-in of us and then yeah and
then or ourselves let's say but when we
do that process where we're aiming to
make real liberal but we're using these
words to make relationships yes for
other people to understand how we think
about the relationships between them
exactly exactly and so that's all the
grammar is that's all that grammar is
it's sort of baking in these very
complex conceptual relationships into
the words you are using and that allows
for very fast and efficient
communication relationships between
words we are using yeah yeah words that
denote objects in the world all the
worlds adeney yeah words it D no objects
in the world yeah yeah yeah interesting
and that's yeah that's how this so crazy
to think about how this evolved from the
soup yeah yeah it is yeah it's it's very
hard to think about you know how would
have always assumed and also where was
the optimization like what were the most
optimizing parts of this like the best
parts yeah and what are ones that are
just bad like which like what parts of
linguistics are just are just there they
just require so much time to learn and
they're not that effective as tools
they're they what is it the most you
it's a high fidelity aspects of language
let's say sure so I think the grammar is
actually the highest utility feature of
language it's it's hard for me to think
of you said like what were the worst
thing so I've done this interesting
experiment with with people I I
basically showed them this and I teach
them a little bit about grammatical
categories and how they work and si and
and sometimes they ask well this is
interesting could you use this to create
new grammatical categories new
conceptual structures yes and what I say
as well it's an interesting question can
you think of some yourself right now
yeah that's exactly this is where all
the hardest yeah exactly and but but yes
so you might think well no I can't but
that's not totally true you could think
of new ways to do this the actual
problem you run into is thinking of new
grammatical categories and structures
conceptual structures that are not that
are not really annoying and useless yeah
correct right it's hard to think of what
in fact
think it's it's it's it might not be
totally impossible but it seems almost
impossible to think of ones that would
be more useful than the ones you you
naturally find in human languages right
so the question is then your the the I
your function when you ask that question
what you're telling me to do find and
make a new grammatical pattern in my
mind automatically thinks of what is the
what's the highest utility of your
grammatical pattern so when you're
trying to basically trying to put fill
human existence into a grammatical
pattern that was used most often exact
to make it high civility exactly and
have you what have you come up with with
this I think I think basically all the
grammatical categories that exist have
extremely high utility I think I think
they're all super high utility and it's
um it's sort of difficult to like say
that one is more useful than the other
it's sort of like tense is extremely
useful in describing time right it's
very good to be able to almost
automatically convey whether something
happened in the past whether you think
it'll happen in the future if it's
happening right at the moment
definiteness is it's pretty useful too I
think you mentioned earlier that the is
the most common word in the English
language
of course yeah and the is is the word
you know there we go the word it is the
word in the English language that um
denotes definiteness which is also a
grammatical category and so the the
values of that category in English would
be definite and indefinite it would just
be binary and so definite would be the
word indefinite would be a word
definiteness you know sort of indicating
whether the the subject at hand is a
particular particular I'm trying to
think of the rights I'm holding a book
versus I'm holding V yeah yeah it's like
it's like you aren't you are able to
very quickly and easily convey whether
an object you are discussing an object
that is a the topic of the conversation
is a particular member of a class or a
set or any member of a class or set okay
right interesting
particularity yeah exactly exactly okay
so become the definite the definitive
exactly exam and and and so that's
pretty useful that's pretty useful right
because if you you know and it's funny
because not all languages have this like
Slavic languages don't don't have over
definiteness like and this is why what
like you don't have the or a in Russian
and this is why if you hear if you hear
like a stereotypical Russian accent like
on a TV show or something they'll say
things like I have booked they won't say
I have a book or I have the book they'll
say I have book yeah because you
wouldn't there's no word for the in
Russian right the definiteness is
contextual and so this is how you get
into a you know the the diagrams gone
but you know you you think about those
diagrams this is how you get into
different languages you might say having
different combinations of diagrams that
are that are present in the in the
explicit explicit sort of production of
the language and this is where the I
think the most difficulty in a language
learning shows up because it is really
conceptual it's not you know people
think learning a language is hard
because I have to I have to memorize so
many words now it's true that memorizing
words is very is difficult the rote
member to memorization I believe of
Mandarin characters something like 6000
remember something of the BA yeah it's
it's it's yeah with Mandarin it would be
um you have to memorize 6000 individual
characters to what what do they call it
to be like conversing or to have sort of
daily literacy I think the total number
of characters in man doing is more like
eighty thousand a yeah create some yeah
and then and then when you see a word in
English and you don't know it you can
sound it out but in manners you don't
know you can't you can't even interpret
it yeah yeah yeah exactly
these are some interesting differences
between languages yes and and
we could we could talk for so long about
yes I know we can that's why I'm saying
it Ronnie I know which you know we'll
have to come back and do part two on on
on over all things
linguistics especially as you continue
evolving what you're building in your
mind I want to ask you some more
thoughts the on a on a you know we
touched on this a little bit but really
on a on an on an ideal language side of
things and you know child's born into
the world we're we're trying to we're
trying to help the child make sense of
the world right we're teaching these
words that give they give context and
relationships outside of them and stuff
and I'm interested to know about like on
a on a potential like on a neuroscience
Plus on a like on a Pareto distribution
side of things like well you know we I
mean we're hinting at this so much
earlier but like what is on and I like
I'm an ideal side of things it's just so
hard to you know like he said what is a
ideal grammar pattern what would be an
ideal thing to teach a child as we go
into this let's mesh this actually with
the technology such a question actually
yeah you know we're moving away from
some of the limitations we have in these
words love can mean so many different
things as a word but a thought with
something like you know like a brain
computer interface pre machine to face
these types of these ways of potentially
synchronizing what what someone is
thinking with the with with what another
person understands about it with a
hundred percent accuracy instead of
doing this or what did you mean with
that
yeah so yeah tell us about what your
thoughts are about kind of optimizing
the utility of words and grammar and
yeah with technology so I have a few
thoughts I I do have some friends who
were working on brain computer
interfaces they they haven't hooked me
up yet but uh maybe maybe when they do
all I'll have some direct experience of
what the possibilities are but um you
know it helps to think when you talk
about this stuff it's interesting
because the brain computer interface
ideally if you sort of look at like the
kinds of things you see in science
fiction could be a replacement
it could be a replacement technology for
for language in other words that
language and this are trying to solve
the same problem which is how to
communicate things that happen here over
there with high fidelity fidelity yeah
and so if so so language is is how we
solve this problem basically I think
right in the past I've got a lot of
things going on up here got a lot of
things going on over there if we combine
the two we could both benefit but how do
we do that well we have a language we
have a system of sounds and then later
symbols so that that can be transferred
over time we have very complex rules
about how it works that allows us to be
to have the fidelity basically we have a
lot of words that allows us to have
great sort of coverage if we were able
to communicate telepathically all that
might just be pointless basically right
language might just be obsolete yeah you
wouldn't need if if I could just you
know a lot of people have internal
monologues where they sort of their
brain is like sort of talking in their
head is how they describe it I mean
maybe you do I definitely do have yeah
so some people don't some people don't
and all thought is definitely not verbal
all of it is definitely not you see
images you remember smells you get like
that's right weird movements that you
can't even put into words basically like
like the mind is a big place not all of
it is linguistic you speed so yes yeah
yeah yeah exactly exactly and so if you
were able to directly transfer that
somehow with high fidelity then what
would the point of language being yeah
yeah and then well then maybe the the it
becomes a thought to thought yeah yeah I
thought thinking - thinking feeling -
feeling experience to experience quality
- quality a title of the thing rather
than the ambiguity of using via words
exactly exactly and you know if we don't
get to I mean perfect telepathic
communication obviously this is a pretty
speculative thing right now people are
trying to do something like that if they
if they get let's say let's let's say
they get halfway there
you could definitely integrate that sort
of technology with with language as it
exists now and and improve language and
so for example like I was discussing
earlier a lot of people just have just
have arguments about semantics they
don't actually agree on the definitions
of words so it might be very interesting
if if you took some more some more
abstract some more abstract words like
spirit soul mind brain mm-hmm
these are these are four words that are
different have have different meanings
but it's a bit difficult to pin down
exactly how different the meanings are
because they're they're very abstract
right brain is less abstract but it's
related to the other three will make us
yeah consciousness yeah let's say yeah
let's add five consciousness conscience
I'd say six right yeah so it's like you
know we know the difference between
water and orange juice very clear very
obvious difference right differences
between these six things brain mind you
know not as clear not obvious not
obvious and people probably end up in a
lot of arguments over over reality
because they don't they don't realize
like I might be using the word spirit
and you might you might have a different
meaning for spirit that is difficult for
us to to to get to the bottom of so if
you had sort of brain computer
technology I mean I'm not sure exactly
how it would work but maybe it could
help accurately quantify these these
differences in meaning in people's heads
basically yeah yep yep that's it I've
said there's people's heads making a
Blackie I'd the more direct direct
quality of communication that exists so
it's interesting exactly alright now
wrapping on our show we like to ask
questions for our guests yeah the first
question right yeah yeah that's right a
first question we're gonna ask you is
are we alone in the cosmos ooh
interesting interesting
so I would I would start off my answer
by recommending that that you and
everybody who's everybody who's
listening checks out the polish science
fiction writer
Stanislav LEM that's LEM very few people
know about him but this is one of this
is one of his key questions and his
answer is is the answer that I have he's
got a lot of great novels I highly
recommend Solaris that might be the most
famous one but his answer is basically
this if there was life out in the
universe that we didn't know about the
universe could be teeming with life in
fact and it might just be impossible for
us not just to communicate but to even
notice and why is that because the
universe has such a huge sort of
possibility space it's like if there's
life out there we wouldn't just have to
be able to sort of speak a common
language
we'd have to be on the same scale
scientific level not scientific progress
of literal being so let me put it this
way what if there are what if there are
civilizations so small they are smaller
than the smallest particles that we've
identified like ants on like on another
yeah sure or pop are smaller in part
what was smaller than that what if there
what if there are beings so big that
they're planets or something yeah like
yeah which is actually the plot of
Solaris in fact we're definitely on the
same wavelength here but interesting
what if there are beings whose lifespan
is a billion years yeah they would just
never notice us what if what if they're
beings whose life span is is like a
nanosecond of a nanosecond or whatever
right the possibility space is huge the
possibility space for what intelligence
means is huge like like there there
there are so many assumptions in the
sort of idea of a Martian arriving right
there's so many assumptions that we
would be on the same level as them not
just in terms of civilization but
literally just literally existence size
time life span
thought-process what if there are you
know gravity gravity is a force that
exists in the universe that we don't
even fully understand even though it
really directly affects our lives if we
don't take it seriously what if there
are other forces that we just haven't
discovered yet that can sustain some
sort of life that's not that's not
physical material life in the sense that
we think of it right I mean like we
literally just have no idea what's out
there and this is basically the point of
Stanislav Lemon and it's sort of I look
at it - there could be there could be
beings here right now that we just
cannot perceive and they cannot perceive
us right we don't know enough about the
nature of reality - to have a good
handle on the possibility space and then
definitely say well it's unlikely that
they're out there or it is likely that
it's out there now I know about Fermi's
paradox and stuff like this an
assumption there is that is that the
aliens that Fermi is looking for in
describing are on our sort of scale you
know right I love how you went to the
imagination space yeah that's very
important and we you know that's one of
the reasons why our show is simulation
because you know we have really got to
think in an abstract imaginative way
about civilizations and yeah one could
have some really evolved in this massive
imagination space two more questions
next one is we got one more cliff to
simulation we got one more question
okay okay okay this is simulation so we
must ask you are we in a simulation yes
okay no hesitation 100% 100% 100%
all world religions and spiritual
traditions held the position that we
live in a simulation they just didn't
use that word what did these
they just called it the world but the
way they describe the world right like
like you have to ask yourself what is a
simulation what are the features of a
simulation a simulation has rules a
simulation is created by someone it's
created someone for some purpose
presumably right what are other sort of
abstract you know conditions we can use
let's just use those three so simulation
is a math test yeah yes exactly there's
a test exactly it has rules it has a
creator it has a purpose all world
religions believe this about the world
there are rules there's a creator and
there's a purpose right I'm sure and so
a simulation doesn't have to be a it
doesn't have to be in binary digits or
whatever basically right it could be you
could run you know very interesting
kinds of simulations you know it's like
it doesn't have to be that per se and
even if it is test it's all the same you
know to us it's all the same for part of
the simulation so so yes I would say yes
well and I would say it is a simulation
because I look at the world I do think
there are rules in the world laws of
physics and whatnot I think I think
there is a creator of some kind and I
think that I think rules have to come
from some sort of some sort of
intelligence of some kind and I have not
quite figured out the purpose I don't
know if anybody has but it seems like
we're all heading somewhere if you see
what I mean and so yeah given that those
three conditions are satisfied I think
we do in fact live in a simulation and
and I think we're all in agreement on
that given where we're heading yes yes
that's very interesting
this has been absolutely fascinating
thank you so much for coming out so and
telling us all about theoretical
linguistics thank you for having me
thank you absolutely it's been a
pleasure it's been a pleasure I'm glad
you had a good time we're excited to do
an update with you soon yeah we're
really excited to continue seeing your
work evolve everyone check out the work
below - mark was links he's got his
website link below is Twitter link below
go and check those out read them up give
them shares should I do the glasses now
oh yeah I do the glass do the glass you
found my glasses you're a fan of the
glasses look at that holy cow
subscribe to simulation
I love it we're gonna put the double
your pay that was so good so zero
dollars double this still zero dollars
got it yeah okay thanks everyone give us
your thoughts in the comments below on
linguistics on all these different
things than what we talked about going
to share these types of thoughts with
your communities with your friends with
your families talk about linguistics
more and how we evolved to actually get
to this point that we're at today
support the artists and entrepreneurs
that you believe in all simulations
links are below support the ones in your
communities as well help us grow you
shout out to Ron Vargas for producing
and directing we love you very much
thank you and go and build the future
everyone manifest your dreams into the
world thank you for tuning and we'll see
you soon
peace
[Music]
you
[Music]